[Música]
los países desarrollados y también
muchos países emergentes como es el caso
de la misma china empiezan a ver cada
vez con más preocupación los efectos que
pueden causar el envejecimiento
demográfico y la insostenibilidad de
muchos servicios públicos
junto a las pensiones de las que ya
hemos hablado aquí en visual político la
sanidad es otro de los campos que más
incertidumbres y miedos generan
una población cada vez más envejecida y
la aparición de nuevas y costosas
tecnologías médicas han puesto sobre la
mesa algunas preguntas muy importantes
seremos capaces de pagar un sistema
sanitario de calidad o estaremos
condenados a una sanidad precaria que
afecta a nuestras perspectivas de vida
existe algún modelo de éxito que pueda
marcar el camino hay alternativas
para contestar a estas y otras preguntas
hoy tenemos con nosotros a nuestro buen
amigo juan ramón rallo doctora en
economía y director del instituto juan
de mariana y ojo porque me parece que
este vídeo nos va a sorprender mucho
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
atentos al siguiente gráfico refleja un
país abandonando el tercer mundo y
convirtiéndose en una de las zonas más
ricas del planeta hace 35 años
singapur y españa tenían la misma renta
per cápita hoy en cambio la del primero
más que duplica la renta per cápita
española 2015 los ingresos per cápita de
singapur fueron de 86 mil 100 euros
anuales y los de españa apenas llegaron
a 34 mil 750
pero incluso si tomamos como ejemplo a
países como finlandia dinamarca suecia
alemania o los mismísimos eeuu podemos
ver como singapur se ha convertido en
mucho más rico que cualquiera de ellos
[Música]
sin embargo suele alegar sé que el
ejemplo de singapur no sirve porque su
riqueza procede esencialmente de un
sector financiero mucho mayor que el de
cualquiera de los países que hemos
mencionado eso es cierto pero no es esa
la clave del éxito de este pequeño
estado el peso del sector financiero en
singapur no es tan grande como para
explicar semejantes diferencias de renta
per cápita de hecho si elimináramos el
efecto del diferente tamaño del sector
financiero entre estos países
singapur seguiría siendo mucho más rico
que todos los demás
lo cierto es que tanto el comercio como
la industria manufacturera son más
importantes en singapur que el sector
financiero hablamos de uno de los
mayores países exportadores de
mercancías del mundo por ejemplo este
país exporta más material de electrónica
en relación con su pib que todo lo que
exportan por cualquier concepto países
como españa suecia dinamarca o incluso
la mismísima alemania entonces la
pregunta es cómo ha conseguido singapur
semejante ola de prosperidad
[Música]
pues bien si quisiéramos simplificar un
poco podríamos decir que singapur en la
segunda economía más libre del mundo
según el índice de libertad económica
que publica anualmente la fundación
heritage junto con el wall street
journal su gasto público por ejemplo es
la mitad del estadounidense y un tercio
del sueco fijaos por ejemplo en estas
palabras del histórico presidente de
singapur lee kuan yu que reflejan muy
bien cuáles son cuáles fueron los
auténticos cimientos del éxito económico
de este país y eso que él lee kuan yu no
era un político liberal pero si entendió
muy bien cuáles eran algunas de las
bases de la prosperidad a largo plazo de
cualquier sociedad
cuando la mayoría de países del tercer
mundo denunciaba la explotación de las
multinacionales occidentales en singapur
las invitamos a entrar de ese modo
conseguimos crecimiento tecnologías y
know-how que dispararon nuestra
productividad más de lo que podría
haberlo hecho cualquier política
económica alternativa el éxito de
singapur por tanto no se debe a la
industria financiera sino a las mismas
razones que han explicado el crecimiento
de cualquier otra economía seguridad
jurídica impuestos bajos estabilidad
monetaria y regulaciones moderadas
[Música]
una apuesta por el libre mercado que ha
hecho que este país se convierta en
muchos campos en todo un ejemplo a
seguir
[Música]
y no solo hablamos del ámbito
estrictamente económico sino también en
algunas cuestiones sociales como la
sanidad si habéis escuchado bien
singapur es también un modelo a seguir
en materia sanitaria
[Música]
un reto imposible
demos un vistazo por ejemplo al caso de
españa- cuyas unidades considerada una
de las más eficientes del planeta pues
bien el problema es que más allá de que
sea mejorable no es sostenible fijaos en
apenas una década el gasto total del
sistema sanitario español se ha
multiplicado prácticamente por 2 y todo
indica que como consecuencia del
envejecimiento de la población y de la
demanda de nuevas y caras tecnologías
sanitarias esta tendencia continuará
imparable continuará agravándose a largo
plazo
y no penséis que es un problema sólo de
españa' para nada la factura médica esto
es la sostenibilidad de los sistemas
sanitarios es un problema muy extendido
en el resto de países desarrollados así
que la pregunta que se nos plantea es
cómo lograr superar estos retos y
garantizar la sostenibilidad del sistema
sanitario
el modelo óptimo sería el de un sistema
sanitario completamente libre un sistema
en el que la oferta y la demanda se
determinara en el mercado y no en los
despachos de los políticos frente a lo
que suelen afirmar políticos burócratas
y contertulios en los medios de
comunicación este modelo tendría dos
importantes ventajas primero más dinero
para las familias gracias a los menores
impuestos y a su vez un nivel de ahorro
precaución ario frente a las violencias
que se puedan padecer que sería muy
superior al presidente todo ello
permitiría el pago directo de la
atención primaria y a su vez el
aseguramiento contra dolencias menos
comunes y para tratamientos para
financiar tratamientos más caros
[Música]
y en segundo lugar habría una mayor
diversidad y competencia entre los
distintos centros sanitarios lo que
impulsaría la productividad la
diferenciación con la innovación ante la
amenaza la que se enfrentaría a
cualquiera de estos centros sanitarios
de verse desplazados por otros que
fueran más eficientes a la hora de
proveer servicios sanitarios en otras
palabras lograríamos un amplio abanico
de servicios sanitarios que impactaría
positivamente tanto en la calidad de ese
servicio como a la hora de rebajar
progresivamente sus precios
la competencia suele ser la mejor
fórmula para garantizar mejores bienes y
servicios a los consumidores y la
sanidad simplemente no es un campo
diferente sin embargo a día de hoy no
existe ningún país que combina
adecuadamente todos estos principios y
no el sistema sanitario de eeuu como
luego veremos no es precisamente un
modelo un ejemplo del libre mercado
sanitario ahora bien si hay un país que
ha aplicado algunas de las
características que hemos visto antes y
lo ha hecho por cierto con unos
resultados extraordinarios es atentos el
caso de singapur
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un modelo para la reforma sanitaria
singapur tiene ahora mismo el mejor
sistema sanitario del mundo
su calidad se halla en el top mundial y
su coste es prácticamente la mitad que
el español y menos de un tercio del
sistema sanitario estadounidense
pero no se trata sólo de una cuestión de
costes sino también de calidad y
resultados la esperanza de vida al nacer
en singapur es de 2 a 3 años mayor que
en gran bretaña o eeuu su tasa de
mortalidad infantil se encuentra entre
las más bajas del mundo y es casi la
mitad que la de eeuu gran bretaña
australia canadá o francia en general
sus tasas de mortalidad son
impresionantes en comparación con la
mayoría de países occidentales ahora
bien cómo ha conseguido semejante éxito
pues aplicando criterios de mercado en
primer lugar la característica esencial
del modelo de singapur no sólo es que
más del 60 por ciento de todo el gasto
sanitario es gasto privado sino que
además en gran medida lo sufragan
directamente los usuarios en forma de
pagos directos a la sanidad aquí por
tanto el copago es la norma
[Música]
por ejemplo no todo el mundo paga lo
mismo cuando acude al hospital hay
centros públicos y privados y también
cinco niveles cinco clases diferentes a
b1 b2 b2 y c
cada una de estas letras le otorga a los
usuarios un servicio diferente por
ejemplo la clase a supone habitación
privada y elección de médico mientras
que en la clase c la habitación es
compartida y el médico asignado por el
hospital por supuesto el coste de cada
clase es diferente si se elige la clase
a el usuario paga íntegramente por todo
si en cambio elige la clase c el
gobierno subvenciona el 80% del coste
[Música]
pero de dónde sacan las personas el
dinero para costearse la sanidad pues
del mismo sitio que en los demás países
de la riqueza que genera de su trabajo
la diferencia es que las enormes
cotizaciones que suelen recaudar los
gobiernos en singapur permanecen
obligatoriamente eso sí en unas cuentas
especiales que posee cada ciudadano y
que sólo puede utilizar para
determinados fines como el pago de su
pensión su educación su vivienda o la
sanidad
en el caso justamente de la sanidad la
cuenta se conoce como mehdi safe y se
emplea para costear las visitas al
médico o las hospitalizaciones los
medicamentos etcétera etcétera etcétera
esta es precisamente la segunda clave
del sistema de singapur gracias a esta
fórmula la demanda se autorregula y la
gente no solo puede gestionar cómo
gastar el dinero acumulado en estas
cuentas en el medio 6 por ejemplo por
clases de atención diferentes si quiero
recibir o quiero hospitalizarme en un
hospital con mayores comodidades o en
uno con algunas menos pero a un menor
coste sino que además hace que el
consumo redundante y superfluo sea
minimizado la gente no dilapida su
propio dinero en algo que entienden no
le va a servir para nada y en algo que
incluso su médico le puede aconsejar que
no lo gaste
luego está también para los casos más
graves un seguro público universal
conocido como mehdi shield life que
apenas cuesta 16 dólares al mes para una
persona de unos 30 años y junto a ello
por supuesto la posibilidad de contratar
otros seguros privados que mejoren las
prestaciones ofertadas
por último la tercera pata del sistema
sanitario de singapur la compone el
gasto público propiamente dicho con tal
de garantizar el acceso a la sanidad el
gobierno subvenciona hospitales y cuenta
con un fondo público el mehdi fund
destinado a pagar las facturas
sanitarias a las familias con menor
renta
[Música]
así es amigos como singapur ha
conseguido hacer que su sistema médico
sea relativamente económico al tiempo
que logra unos resultados y niveles de
calidad que lo sitúan entre los mejores
sistemas sanitarios del mundo según la
propia organización mundial de la salud
y diferentes rankings como el mosto
fisión healthcare de bloomberg
[Música]
sin embargo lo normal es que cuando
hablamos de sanidad y libre mercado
pensemos automáticamente en estados
unidos y no en singapur y eso es un
grave error
[Música]
eeuu versos singapur
en efecto eeuu carece de un sistema de
sanidad pública al estilo europeo y como
los resultados de la sanidad de
estadounidenses son bastante deplorables
teniendo en cuenta además que hasta el
17 por ciento de su pib en el sistema
sanitario es decir el doble que la
mayoría de presos europeos
el debate parece fácilmente zanjado la
sanidad privada es peor que la pública
porque cuesta el doble con un nivel de
servicios similar o en algunos tramos
incluso peor algo que como hemos visto
en el caso de singapur donde el 60% del
gasto es gasto sanitario privado no es
cierto en singapur la sanidad no sólo no
es peor sino que está en el top mundial
de calidad sanitaria y además su coste
es la mitad que en el resto de países
desarrollados
la cuestión es que el sistema sanitario
de eeuu no solo está muy intervenido y
regulado por el gobierno sino que su
coste está tremendamente socializado
veréis en eeuu el 90 por ciento del
gasto sanitario se canaliza a través de
dos agentes distintos del propio
paciente de cada 100 dólares que se
gastan en las unidad estadounidense 45
los desembolsan las aseguradoras y 45
los programas estatales como el medicaid
y el medicare y sólo por tanto 10 el
propio paciente de su propio bolsillo
directamente para aquellos gastos que
necesitan
y si el gasto público en sanidad de eeuu
es mayor por ejemplo que el de españa y
no me refiero claro en términos
absolutos que sería una obviedad sino
también en términos relativos el
porcentaje del pib de gasto público en
materia sanitaria en programas como el
medicare o medicaid que destina eeuu es
mayor que el que destine españa para
financiar todo su sistema público de
sanidad pero de todo esto podremos
hablar con mayor profundidad en otra
ocasión el caso que ahora nos ocupa es
el de singapur y el caso de singapur
pone sobre la mesa un modelo de sistema
sanitario con la mejor combinación de
coste innovación y resultados médicos
por todo ello no estaría nada mal que
nuestros políticos le echaran un vistazo
y quizá se animaban a copiar algo para
nuestra sociedad un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]